Cool.
Hello everyone and welcome to lecture
three of CME 295.
Um so today is a very exciting day
because we're going to finally introduce
large language models.
Uh but I guess before we go into that,
I'm just going to start traditionally
with some announcements.
Um so some of you wanted to have the
slides before the class. So just a
heads-up that in case you want to use
the slides to do some annotations,
uh they're on the website right now. So
feel free to get them.
And we Shervin will try to just on a
regular basis every Thursday evening
have them published on the websites so
that you can download them and annotate.
Cool.
So with that, let's start.
And as usual, we're going to recap
last week's episodes.
So if you remember, you know, lecture
one and lecture two were all about
introducing the concept of
self-attention
and linking them to the construct of the
transformer.
And what we did last lecture was look at
all the types of models that there are
out there and how they were all based on
the transformer.
So there are three categories, three
main categories of models.
So the first one that we saw was
encoder-decoder model,
which basically relies on the
transformer. It has the encoder of the
transformer, the decoder of the
transformer, and typically the tasks
there are input text, so text in, text
out.
So we saw that one example was T5
and all the variations.
The second type of model is where we
remove the decoder from the trans-
transformer and we obtain an
encoder-only model.
So, uh we went uh deeper into BERT,
which is the typical encoder-only model.
And uh I guess we also saw that what
BERT has is this nice property that its
encoded embeddings are very meaningful
and expressive of the inputs.
And so, yeah, we saw like the example of
classification, sentiment extraction.
So, what we did was
in particular, um
taking to consideration the encoded
embedding of the CLS token.
So, uh I guess in real life, BERT is
used to encode documents, to encode
sentences, and we're going going to see
later in the class how these models are
useful.
And then, last but not least, we have
the third category of models, which is
decoder-only.
So, we only keep the decoder part of the
transformer.
And so, here we also do a little bit of
a of a modification, so we remove the
cross-attention cuz we don't need it
anymore. We don't have an encoder.
And
these kinds of models are text-in,
text-out.
And so, GPT is a very good example of
such models.
And actually, most models these days,
they're only like they're decoder-only.
So, these are the three main kinds of
models that you can see out there.
So far, so good for everyone?
Cool. So, with that, I'm going to
introduce the term LLM. So, LLM
stands for large language model.
So, what is a large language model?
So, first of all,
a large language model is a language
model.
So, a language model is a model
that assigns probability to sequences of
tokens.
So, in this case, our model always
predicts the probability of the next
token.
So, it's in that sense
a language model.
But also, a large language model is
large. So, why is it large? So, we're
going to see that these models,
they are actually scaled up in terms of
size.
So, first of all, in terms of model
size. So, these days, it's not uncommon
to see models on the order of hundreds
of billions of parameters.
But yeah, typically, when we say LLM, we
say at least on the order of a billion.
Um these models they've also been
trained on a huge amount of data. And
here, by amount of data, we quantify
that by the number of tokens that they
were pre-trained with.
And this is on the order of magnitude of
hundreds of billions of tokens or even
trillions of tokens.
So, I think the biggest biggest ones are
like on the tens of trillions of tokens.
So, it's like huge
training sets.
And they're also large because they need
a lot of compute. So, typically, you
need a bunch of GPUs to make them work.
Although these days, there's been a lot
of
optimizations to have them work on uh
consumer-based GPUs. So, we're going to
see that later.
But an LLM is large according to these
categories.
So, another thing that I want to point
out is that all these terminologies,
they're relatively new.
So, um I remember in 2018-19
there was nothing like there was no real
definition of an LLM. I think no one
actually talked about LLMs. In the
beginning maybe people talked about
LLMs, they included BERT.
But BERT is an encoder only model that
does not produce text.
So with the current definition of an
LLM, which right now has been pretty
well established,
BERT would not
be an LLM because it doesn't produce
text.
So here we only consider
language models that do text-to-text
that are very large in size
in terms of amount of data they've been
trained on and in terms of compute.
Cool.
And as we saw before, these models are
decoder only.
So here what we do is we remove the
encoder, we only keep the masked
self-attention,
the feedforward neural network, and then
the you know, addition and
normalization.
So we only keep this.
And this is the backbone
of LLMs.
And so I mentioned you know, GPT is a
kind of a good example, but it's not
just that. You have plenty of other
models. So you may have heard of Llama
from Meta,
Gemma from Google,
Deep Seek, Mistral, Guan, so on. Like
the the list is long.
I would say roughly I mean more than 90%
of
like modern-day LLMs, they're all
decoder only.
So I think that's something to keep in
mind.
Cool.
Um
Okay. So now you know how LLMs are made
of,
but there is something else that
people these days also introduced to
these models, and we're going to see
that in a bit.
So I mentioned that these models are
huge in size.
Again, typically hundreds of billions of
parameters.
So it takes
a lot of compute
to just compute one inference.
Or also to train these models.
But you may wonder,
do you really need to have all these
parameters be activated during a forward
pass to make a simple prediction?
So I'm going to uh
I have a little metaphor.
So let's suppose you enter in a room
and in the room there is
a mathematician,
a physicist,
a chemist,
and a historian.
So you come in this class, there's a
bunch of people who are expert in what
they do.
And you have a question you have a math
question.
And so the question I have for you is
who would you ask your question?
Would you ask the mathematician? Would
you ask the chemist? Would you ask
everyone?
Well, right now we ask everyone.
We ask all parameters of the model to be
involved in the computation of
uh you know, the generation.
And so the idea here is
given an input,
maybe it's not necessary to ask everyone
to be involved in the computation.
So the idea is let's actually just have
a subset of the model
be involved in the computation of the
next token.
So I'm just introducing this idea of
experts. So let's suppose we're
introducing uh the following notation.
So let's suppose we have n experts.
So think of it as your mathematician,
your chemist, historian, like whatever.
So these are your experts.
And the idea is
given an input x
you're going to ask yourself
who should be involved in the
generation of the outputs.
So you're going to have
let's say another network. We're going
to We're going to call it g like gates.
But it's also sometimes called router.
So let's suppose we have some gates
that tells us
which expert should be involved
in the inference.
So if we have that So let's suppose here
the gate tells us, "Okay, so actually
expert number two is well suited to
answer your question." So here the idea
is that the input is just going to flow
into that expert.
But not the other experts.
So this
has a name.
It's called mixture of experts. So it's
So denoted MOE.
Everyone talks about MOE. So these are
mixture of experts. And so the formula
that you will see a lot is this one.
So the output y, which is denoted y hat,
is the sum
of the expert outputs
weighted by
some quantity, which is the output of
the gates,
which tells you how important
the output of each expert is.
Yep.
>> Great question. So, question is how do
you train G? How do you train E? So,
typically you train them jointly.
So, we're going to see that maybe in a
Yeah, a little little bit. You can think
of it as, you know, just training as
usual. You do your forward pass, you
compute the loss, and you backprop.
And it's actually an interesting
question because there is some
challenges that come with training MOEs
that we're going to see in a second.
Yep.
Uh question is what are these Es? What
is the architecture of these Es? So,
let's suppose right now that they're
just some network.
We're not specifying them for now, but
we're going to see it to this in a
second. Let's suppose for now it's like
some network.
Cool.
Okay. So, I told you that, you know,
what if we don't activate everyone? What
if we activate a subset? But this
formula actually
um
I guess uh assumes that we're actually
considering all expert outputs.
So, I just want to distinguish two kinds
of MOEs.
So, there's one kind that is called a
dense MOE.
So, a dense MOE
actually does not have any constraints
on the number of experts that are
involved.
So, these weights, they can be anywhere
between zero and one. So, so think of
them as a probability distribution.
But it's just going to put more weight
towards some experts compared to others.
So, back back to the example that I had.
So, let's suppose I have
uh a math question. So, I'm going to ask
the mathematician, the chemist,
historian. So, I'm probably going to add
a higher weight to what the
mathematician says compared to let's say
the historian.
So, this is the idea.
But then,
the interesting thing
is when
we constrain the number of experts that
are activated
because here, as we mentioned
previously,
what we're interested in is to not
involve everyone, is to make some
savings in the amount of compute that we
do. So, there's a second kind of MoE
that's called the sparse MoE.
And what it does is it only selects
the
top K
experts.
So, K can be equal to one, so one
expert, or even two.
So, it's a hyperparameter that you
choose.
And so here, the expression of the
output becomes the sum
over all the chosen experts of
uh g of x times uh e of x.
So far, so good?
Cool. Uh and of course, there's a lot
more to it. So, in case you are
interested in learning more, uh feel
free to go into the resources that are
at the bottom of the slide.
Um so, one thing that I will say
is that we have a unit of measure of the
amount of compute that these models
produce uh for each uh each pass. So,
you will see the term flops.
So, have you Have you seen the term
flops out there?
No, not really. So, it stands for
floating-point
operations.
So, it quantifies how many operations,
like think of it as like additions,
multiplications,
are involved in a forward pass, let's
say.
And it basically quantifies how
compute-heavy is your task.
So, typically, what we say is
when we go through a sparse MoE as
opposed to a dense MoE
we have a lower
amount of flops.
So, this is the unit of measure that you
will see.
But, back to your question.
So, what are these experts?
So, if you remember
I mean
10 minutes ago, we said that LLMs
they are decoder-only models.
So, I have a question for you.
Let's suppose we wanted to put some MoEs
in our LLM
where we would we put it?
So, here, I guess we have uh three
choices. We have uh the mass
self-attention layer.
We have the
uh feedforward neural network, and then
we have like this normalization. So
question for you, I guess where would
you put this?
I guess where do you think
is I guess the most complex parts of the
network? Where is there a lot of
operations?
Feedforwards? Yes. Yeah, great great
answer. So
uh it's indeed the feedforward neural
network.
And the reason for that is I think uh
Shervin uh mentioned it, I think, in
lecture one.
So, if you remember, the feedforward
neural network is a network such that
you have the inputs which is your, you
know D-dimensional
input vector
and then you have uh this being
projected into, let's say, uh
DFF-dimensional
space, and then it goes back to the D
dimensional
um I guess uh space. So, the DFF
is typically larger than
your
dimension of I guess the inputs.
When I say input is here.
So, it's typically larger, so
the amount of parameters that you have
in that feedforward neural network is
something on the order of magnitude of D
model * DFF
* 2 plus some bias. So, it's basically
your order of magnitude.
And
the attention layer, if you think about
if you remember, it's basically composed
of the projection matrices.
What is the dimension of the projection
matrices? So, it's
D model * the dimension of keys, the
dimension of queries, the dimension of
values.
And this dimension is typically much
lower.
So, think of it over 100.
So, your D model is typically over 100,
over 1,000.
And then the projection here, the DFF
is over over 1,000, over 10,000.
Cool. So, is everyone now convinced that
this is a good way good place to put the
mixture of experts?
Yeah?
Cool. So,
this is actually how it's done. So, in
modern-day day LLMs,
this idea of not involving everyone in
the computation of the next token
prediction
is such that you would put put the
mixture of experts
where the FFN is.
It's basically here.
And typically you would have a sparse
mixture of experts,
meaning that So, back to your question,
so these experts are actually uh feed
forward neural network. So, you wouldn't
you would have several networks that you
can train.
But you would only activate activate
one.
So, typically K would be equal to one.
It can be also equal to two, but it
would only be a subset, so that's my
point.
Um
and
this routing
would be done at the token level.
So, if you remember, you know, the
decoder, it basically takes
uh something as input, so you you know,
a bunch of tokens.
And here what I'm saying is that each
token
will be processed by an expert that may
be different from the other token.
So, the writer router here
would take
the representation of the token as input
and figure out which expert should be
best for this token to flow towards.
Does this idea make sense?
So, I have a little um
illustration later on that
hopefully will help.
So, now back to your question about how
you train this model, like do you train
the router separately, do you train the
expert separately?
So,
one challenge that people have
is when they train these MoE-based
models
to make sure that all experts
are I guess having a weight,
are being used.
Cuz it's very possible that you train
your model
and that somehow only, I don't know, one
or two experts always get activated.
And the other one, they always are
inactive. They're never involved in the
computation.
So, this problem is called routing
collapse. So, why is it called routing
collapse? It's because the router
always chooses some experts, but not
others.
So, this is a challenge.
And the way people try to mitigate this
challenge
is by changing the loss function
and adding it some extra term, which is
written here.
So, it's basically some hyperparameter
alpha
times the number of experts
times
the sum of
quantities that depend on whether or not
tokens went to a certain expert I, and
then summed over all experts.
So, it's not super important that you
completely understand exactly how that
formula works.
The only thing that I think you should
take away from this slide
is that this
extra loss
allows these quantities
to converge more towards uniform
distributions. So, what are these
quantities just as a reminder? So, f of
I
is the fraction of tokens
that are routed to expert I.
And p of I is the average routing
probability for expert I.
So, when I say that, you know, all
experts should be used
kind of
the same
what I'm saying is I want this
probability to be kind of uniform
across experts.
Yep.
Yeah, so the question is I guess
when do you compute these quantities? So
yeah, like you can think of it as like
you know a regular training
process like you know you do some like
mini batch. You can have like go go
through that through like the the model
and then you compute all these
quantities and then what you do is you
do your
your back propagation based on that.
And I guess what I want you to remember
is that this
incentivizes
the probability
I guess the
the choice of the router to be more
uniform across experts
which
is something that mitigates this routing
collapse phenomena.
Yeah.
Yeah, so the question is can we use
dropout? Of course, you can always like
bundle that with some other techniques.
So people have just kind of found this
to be very helpful. So speaking of other
techniques, there is something that I've
not talked about which is very similar
to the dropout
idea. So it's called noisy gating.
Noisy gating is basically
uh you have
your
your predictions from the gates, but
then you add some noise to it.
So basically it's you know by pure
chance it just allows other experts to
be involved in the computation. So it's
also some other technique. There's a
bunch of techniques, but yeah dropout is
indeed quite useful for like things like
overfitting and the idea can be reused
in in different settings.
Yep.
So, the question is how can you differ-
So, you mean differentiable?
So, here I guess how do you take the
derivative? Is that your
the question?
Uh, how is the derivative So, can you
explain a bit more what your concern is?
Mhm. So, I guess uh, to this question
um, so the average routing probability
So, that's one is a function of
the gates outputs,
right?
That's one.
PI
Right? So, I guess your question is for
FI.
For FI
Okay, I don't have a good answer on top
of my head, but I think like people have
some techniques and these days, you
know, you just don't even have to do
this by hand. You have uh, like the
built-in thing. Um, so maybe I can
follow up with you for FI, but for P of
I, do you see that this one is is quite
clean. It's just the average of uh, the
probabilities from the gates.
Uh, yeah. So, basically the probability
of the output probability from the the
gate, you can think of it as
just the vector being projected on a
space of N, where N corresponds to your
number of experts.
And then it's gone through softmax, so
your output is basically summing up to
one.
And
each of these dimensions, they represent
the value corresponding to what expert I
would be, I guess, used for. Like, for
instance, the first dimension would be
for expert one, second dimension would
be for expert two, and so on.
So, you just take the average of this
and like this one, you can express it
from, you know, all the parameters. So,
I think you should be you should be fine
with that one.
Yeah.
So, the question is, if we increase the
number of MoEs, does it increase the
number of model parameters? So, it's a
great question. So, it's actually
actually one of the ideas behind
MoE-based models, which is that you can
scale the model
without having to incur the costs of
having significantly more compute at
inference time.
So, you can increase the model's
capacity. You can increase your the
capacity of your model,
but you will still keep some, I guess,
like, controlled amount of active
parameters. And active parameters are
the parameters that are that are used
for a forward pass.
So, yeah, people just kind of use that.
So, yeah, it will just increase the
number of parameters. So, that's why you
see some MoE-based models that are
even bigger than the ones that we kind
of had, like, on the order of hundreds
of billions. We even have on the order
of trillions
of parameters. So, for instance, here,
one reading I I recommend is Switch
Transformer,
which scaled up to 1.something trillion
parameters. So, yeah, it's definitely
more.
Uh but that being said, so if you read
the paper,
you will also see that these models,
they're more what they call sample
efficient.
So, they take less time
to be as good as what the model would
have been
with a lower number of parameters.
So, if you look at like if you uh draw
the you know training training curve uh
as a function of like the training time,
you see that these models, they're
typically more sample efficient.
Sorry?
Yeah, yeah. Exactly. Yeah, everything
here is a trade-off. Everything here is
a trade-off.
Yeah.
Cool.
Um so, the question is each attention
head will have a number of experts. So,
it's actually regardless of the
attention heads.
So, the attention heads are you can
think of them as being like independent,
you know, something else.
And the number of experts is independent
of that.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
Right, right.
All right. Yeah, the question is whether
every block will have number of experts.
It does. So, yes. And typically those
weights, they're not shared.
So, typically you So, actually we're
going to see an example.
Um
it can very well be that layer one,
there is the expert number I don't know,
three that was chosen, but layer two,
there is like expert number one. And you
know, it's
it's like it's all free. It's trainable.
So, the So, the question is we will
decide where to where the expert will go
to. So all of that is decided by the
gates,
which is this quantity.
Everything is decided by the gates,
which has trainable weights.
So you can think of this as just some
projection from the inputs X to an
N-dimensional space, where N is the
number of experts.
So question is at what point were the
inferences decided? So
let's suppose we're at inference time.
I'm going to walk you through how it
works.
So you have your X.
So you have this, you know, attention
mechanism, so it interacts with
tokens from the past given that this
decoder only, so it's like the masked.
It goes here.
And at the beginning of the feedforward
neural network block,
the token is of course contextual, so it
has the information from like these
other tokens because it's attended.
And what it does is it goes here.
So X first goes into G.
G computes
this, you know, probability distribution
over all experts.
And given here that we are in a sparse
MOE setting, we will only choose the top
K. So let's suppose if it's top one,
just
the highest probability
and you will you will know which experts
this one will be.
And so as a result of that, you will
only compute the
the output value of the expert that the
input was chosen.
So can you elaborate on that actually?
Yeah.
At what point exactly? So, it's after
the self-attention layer.
Yeah.
Uh so, the question is uh do we have
different classification for different
heads? No.
So, there's only one router.
So, uh I think I I understand your
question. So, your question is what do
you do given that you have different
attention computations going on in
parallel with the heads? So, if you
remember, the attention layer has its
these different heads,
but at the end of it, what it does is it
concatenates all the results from each
of these heads, and then projects it
once again in the D model space.
Yep.
Mhm.
Yes, so the question is do we have
different G's? So, the only thing I can
tell you is that the G is just layer
specific. It's layer specific, it's
trainable, so it's basically going to
learn how to process all these inputs.
So, the G the only thing I can tell you
for for your question is it's going to
be layer specific, so the G is going to
be one G for let's say the first layer,
another G for the second layer, and so
on. And that's when it's going to be
trained.
Cool.
Great. Looking at the time. Do we have
any other questions here?
All good.
Perfect.
So, now I just wanted to show you a cool
thing that's
I believe
the Mistral team was showing in one of
their papers. So, what they were showing
here was
for a given
piece of text
to show in which expert each token was
routed.
So, as we noted before,
um
so, experts are different from one layer
to another. So, I believe here it's
yeah, for layer zero, so it's like for
one given layer.
And we do see that
you know,
roughly these tokens, I guess they
leverage
like a uniform amount of experts, more
or less.
What you would not want to see is to
have every token be the same color.
But luckily, it is not.
But yeah, so that's one cool way of just
representing how the routing is done is
to just
have your input text and just represent
where each token in which expert
each token went.
Cool.
Okay.
Woof. So, what we just saw was
one way that modern day LLMs
change their architecture to incorporate
the fact that we may want to scale the
model
but not increase the computation
complexity for one forward pass. And we
saw that with MoEs.
So, you will see a lot of MoE-based LLMs
out there.
And now what we will do is
knowing that we have an LLM,
we're going to focus on
Uh don't worry.
Uh we're going to focus on how a
response is being generated.
So, remember when I told you that, you
know, these uh modern-day LLMs, what
they do is they take some text in and
they have some text out.
So, it's typically this task task of
next token prediction. So, you have a
token in, so let's say beginning of
sentence, you go through your LLM, and
it just uh generates the next word or
the next token, so A, and then you take
A, and then it goes to teddy, and then
teddy bear is, etc., etc.
But, so far,
we have never really dug into exactly
how we chose
the next token.
So, what we're going to do right now is
to see exactly how
we're generating the next token.
So, as you know, here
our LLM is just a decoder-only
architecture. So, here what you have is
a decoder with your input here, and then
your output there.
So, let's suppose for a second
that we know everything that's happening
in the middle,
and we're just obtaining
output probabilities
that are going to look a little bit like
this.
So, given a token or some sequence of
token as inputs, you have
an output probability distribution
that represents what the model thinks
is the likelihood that there will be a
next token, let's say that is equal to
A, to airplane, to fluffy, etc.
So, this is what you have.
So, now my question to you is
if we told you we have some sequences
inputs and we want to choose the next
token,
and if I told you that our model is
giving out actually a probability
distribution,
I guess how would you choose the next
token
based on this?
Sorry?
Great. The token with maximum
probability.
There's Okay, great. So yes, so first
idea, let's just take the token with
highest probability.
So
so it's a very natural approach, but I'm
not sure if you've been using things
like ChatGPT or Gemini,
every time you ask something,
it always responds it responds something
that is slightly different,
right?
So if you always choose the token with
the highest probability,
given that the computation here we're
going to see is all deterministic,
what that means is you're always going
to generate the same thing
regardless of
uh I guess with the same inputs,
right? So that's the one one limitation,
so it's not very like diverse.
The second problem is
if you choose
the highest probability token
on a I guess iterative basis,
you're locally optimal,
but you're not necessarily globally
optimal.
So what does that mean? So I guess if
you think about it,
our objective
is for us to produce a sequence an
output sequence of tokens
that is I guess of a high probability.
But the problem is if you always choose
the highest probability token,
you will not necessarily the highest
probability sequence.
Are you convinced of this statement, by
the way?
So, let me give you an example. So,
let's suppose you have the next token
where one token is 0.8, the other one is
0.7.
And then
you choose to go with the 0.8. No,
actually it's not 0.7 because it has to
sum to one. So, let's say 0.2.
So, let's suppose if you go ahead with
the sequence that that
starts with the 0.8.
Let's suppose all other token
probabilities are very low.
Basically, you will have an output
sequence that will have a lower
probability than let's say
the other path
which would let's suppose have higher
probability predictions in the later
steps.
Right? So, we're going to see this in a
second, but this is the idea. So, if you
choose the highest predicted probability
it's a good first idea, but it's locally
optimal, but not necessarily globally
optimal.
And this is the reason why we have a a
second
method
that is about
keeping track
of the K most probable path.
So, I'm not sure if you've heard of beam
search. So, that's what beam search
does.
So, here K is sometimes called
the beam size or the beam width. So, if
you hear these terms, these are just
names that are given to the number of
path that we keep track of.
And so, this works as follows.
So, let's suppose we start our
generation with the beginning of
sentence token.
We want to figure out what the next
token is.
So, let's suppose we have
here in this example a very basic
example like three tokens
and let's suppose the two
highest probable tokens are A and Z.
So if we have K equal to two
what we're going to do is to keep track
of these two branches.
So that's the first iteration.
The second iteration is we're going to
look
at all
the
probabilities
of next token prediction for these two
tokens.
And we're going to always
save the two most probable path.
And here for instance let's suppose if
it's like the and then fluffy and then A
and cute.
So back to what I was saying laters
earlier.
So what I was saying was
here if you were choosing the path
that went along the highest probability
token path like the the
it's very much possible
that the highest
probability token after the would be a
much lower probability than the one
after A.
And so this is what beam search tries to
do. It tries to have a more globally
optimal solution.
So let's suppose we continue that and
then at the end of the day we obtain
uh I guess a number of
uh potential I guess choices uh and the
K potential choices and then we we pick
the one that is the kind of highest
likely.
The sequence with the highest
probability.
So people typically what they do is
they take the sum
of the logarithm of the probabilities
of the tokens. So they they what they
say is they say
uh okay so the
log probability of the sequence is the
sum of the log probability of each next
token prediction. So, it's the log
probability of A
uh knowing BOS and and then cute knowing
BOS and A and so on and so forth.
But, I just want to point out one
limitation of this approach,
which is that
the more you generate tokens,
the lower
your
I guess uh ends
sequence probability will be.
Cuz if you think about it, you know, all
these probabilities are between 0 and 1.
So, think of it like in the kind of
multiplied sense. So, let's suppose you
have the probability of the whole
sequence,
which is just a multiplication of the
probability of the next token.
The more you add probabilities be- below
like
less than one,
the more this quantity will, I guess, go
towards zero.
So, I guess this method as is
will
prioritize sequences that are shorter.
And so, for that reason, beam search has
some uh additional term that basically
counteracts that that effect. So,
something on the order of like
one over number of tokens
to the power of something.
So, in practice, there's some
uh technique to make sure that you know,
things kind of work
relatively well.
But, okay, let's suppose we figure out
all these things.
Uh the problem is that we need to keep
track of this most probable path. We
need to do all this
uh kind of
saving, etc. And it just like requires a
lot of computation.
And the other thing is
we're still interested in the most
probable path
which basically will lead to
a sequence that is, you know, very that
the model thinks is very likely.
But sometimes what you want is for your
output to be more diverse or more
creative.
So that's why beam search
is actually not something that people
typically use.
People use beam search for things like
machine translation where you actually
need to have something that is close to
something being very likely.
But actually people use a third method.
And this method is called also the
sampling method.
So I told you we have
a probability distribution over tokens
regarding what the next token should be.
And so what people do is they just
sample
the next token
using that probability distribution.
Does this make sense?
So in this example
fluffy, gentle, kind, and let's say
smart will have a higher probability of
being drawn as opposed to let's say
airplane and
where that have a lower probability of
occurring. Non-zero probability, but
they have a probability of occurring.
Cool.
Any questions so far?
Yep.
Right. So the question is it's not for
training, it's for inference. Yes,
correct. So this is the You can think of
it as response generation. So let's
suppose you have your model that is
trained. What you want is to generate an
output. So what would you do?
Yeah.
So I guess just to complete my answer,
so during training what you would do is
care about the upper probabilities and
then compare them with the actual label
which is most of the time like a hard
label.
And yeah, this is what you would
compare. So this one is let's suppose
you have an LLM that is trained, how
would you generate a response?
Cool.
All around goods?
Yeah.
Yeah, so question is how do you do
sampling in this situation? So it's
actually my next slides.
But I just want to make sure everyone
was uh
uh on the same page regarding just the
intuition.
So highest probability is called greedy
decoding is probably not something that
we want.
Beam search is a little bit better.
It's more something that is globally
optimal. It's not globally optimal but
more towards that.
So it's better but it lacks diversity,
it lacks creativity which is why what we
want to do is to actually sample
each token.
Um and
I guess we have a few methods that's
um
also restrict
the kinds of tokens that we want to
sample from because I mentioned you know
these very low probability tokens
they can still
again, theoretically be uh sampled but
it's not necessarily something that we
want.
So what people do is they typically
restrict
the highest probability tokens and only
sample from them.
So you may have heard of this term top K
sampling.
Who has heard of this term?
Yeah, a little bit. Okay, so what you do
is you
select the top
highest probable K so the top K highest
probable tokens and you sample from
them.
So, let's suppose if K is equal to 4,
you take the highest four highest
probable and then you just sample with
them.
And there's something else that is quite
similar in idea, which is called top P.
So, top P is
that you limit yourself to the top to
the highest
probable tokens
such that their cumulative probability
is more than a threshold
P.
So, again, it will do the same thing. It
will select the highest probable um
tokens.
But then, there is a part that I still
left out,
which is how do you obtain these
probabilities to start with?
So, if you remember,
here I had mentioned that we just assume
we have the probabilities.
We just have them and we want to choose
what the next token is.
But now, the question that I'm asking is
now that we know
what we will do with these
probabilities, I guess one question is
how do you obtain these probabilities to
start with?
So, if you remember,
these
transformer-based architecture basically
computes an encoder representation of
the input.
And what you have is
some final layers at the very top of the
figure,
which aims at projecting
the vector
into the space of the vocabulary.
Cuz what you want to do is to have a
probability number
for how
probable it is for you to sample a given
token.
Right? So, here what you would do is
at the very top of the of the
architecture have your input, which is
your encoded embedding of the token, go
through a linear layer, which basically
projects your D model vector into
space of dimension
size of V.
And of course, what you want is
probability, so you would have a softmax
layer,
which basically converts everything to
probability such that everything sums to
one.
And in order
to compute the probabilities,
this is the formula that you would use,
which is the softmax layer.
So, there is a
a hyperparameter that is quite important
that I want to talk to you about,
which is the temperature T.
And so, this is where it pops up. So,
you have
the probability of
the next token being a given word, which
is equal to the exponential of the input
respect to the given word over
temperature,
and then you normalize that by the sum
of all the other exponential of the
quantity over T.
And now what we're going to see is
what that T
is used for or what that T actually does
in practice.
So, before we go into that, just one
question. Has anyone heard about
temperatures when it comes to response
generation?
Yeah?
Cool.
So, hopefully that will kind of give you
a better idea of how the temperature
kind of influences your output
predictions.
So, I guess the question that I want to
ask you
is what would be the impact
of having a low temperature
versus a high temperature?
So, low temperature would correspond to
diverse what?
Yeah.
Mhm.
How do you know what? So, we'll we'll
come to that in a second. So, yeah, do
you have a
a lower temperature?
Increasing temperature. So, I guess back
to your
the explanation about like
I guess lowering the temperature and
what impact it will do to the So, I
guess like do you have a suggested
a response to that? I guess like
You lower temperature. Let's suppose you
have a lower temperature, what happens?
Mhm.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, I guess
um
So, the long story short is low
temperature will create a spiky
distribution
and then high temperature will create a
uniform distribution. But, I guess So, I
think you had the right like intuition.
Um
I'm going to maybe write this in more
mathematical terms.
So, oops, okay.
Um let's suppose you have uh don't your
probability,
which is uh you know, the exponential of
xi over t
over the sum
of
exponential of xj over t.
So, just mathematically, you can
actually prove
uh what is happening here. So, let's
suppose
you have the index of the highest xi.
So, let's call that k.
So, let's suppose what I do is
I will
factor by this uh quantity. So, actually
here I don't have space, so let's do
here. So, it will be
a e of
k
temperature, and then here you have
the sum of over all j
of exponential of xj
over t minus
xk over t.
So, what I did is I just multiplied the
numerator and the denominator by
exponential of xk over t.
So, I multiplied numerator and
denominator, and of course they cancel
out.
But then what I have here is xy minus xk
over t, and here xj minus xk over t.
So, when
i is equal to k,
this term is zero,
right? It's exactly zero,
regardless of the the
And here
XJ - AXK
is always negative or zero.
Right?
So here
if I is equal to K
you have
zero
over T. So here it's one.
And then you have one plus
I guess some quantity. So J minus XK
over T, which is going to be negative.
So the T going to zero
so that one will be
I guess
uh going to
let's say minus infinity.
So exponential of minus infinity is
zero.
So what you will end up with is
something where
for I equal to K
you will have a non-zero
probability.
But then for
I not equal to K
you will have
zero
over something that is not equal to
zero.
Which is zero.
So just mathematically, if you factor by
exponential of XK over T
where K is the index of the highest
value
I guess the highest logit or the highest
activation vector
can actually show
that for a small temperature
only the highest
so the index of the
I guess highest
value will be the one that will be I
guess highest probable with a spike
there.
And then when you have a high
temperature,
basically it will
look like a uniform distribution because
all these all these quantities so
when T tends to plus infinity,
this tends to zero. So exponential of
zero is
just e.
Oh, sorry, not e. One.
It's one. So it's one over
the number of J. So it's one so just a
uniform distribution across all
the tokens of your vocabulary.
Yeah.
Um so the question is how can I
interpret a small
Mhm.
Mhm. So the question is can I interpret
that as a Gaussian? I think so it's kind
of tough because Gaussian you have like
some continuous quantity as in the
x-axis. So here you have
you know, you have tokens so it's kind
of discrete
and it's not like something that you can
order. So I'll just probably interpret
that as small temperature is very spiky.
So you you will you will really have
a given set of tokens that are the
highest probable that will appear more.
And if you have a high temperature,
then
basically tokens even the ones that were
not
there to be kind of the highest probable
will actually have an adjusted
probability that that will be higher.
Yes, so you can think of it as like some
kind of scaling in that sense. So long
story short,
what I want to tell you is if you have a
small temperature,
it will encourage the next token to be
geared towards being the highest
probable token.
And then if you if you have a high
temperature,
I guess the distribution of
probabilities will be kind of closer to
a uniform if you really increase that
temperature by a lot.
So, your output will be more creative.
You'll have tokens that
um you would have not drawn that would
be drawn.
And so, what that means in practice, if
you I don't know, if you're with your
favorite LLM,
and let's suppose you want to uh I don't
know, write something very creative.
So, which one would you use? Would you
use a low temperature or high
temperature?
High temperature? Yes. So, if you want
something that's more deterministic,
more I guess closer to
uh something that is very um I guess
what you think would be a high quality,
we'll use more of a lower uh
temperature. So, one note here
is that if you have
a strictly positive temperature,
every time
you run your model over an input,
you will obtain a different output.
Right?
So,
something I want to point out is nothing
in the transformer architecture
is probabilistic. Everything is
deterministic. The only thing that is
not deterministic is how you sample
the next token. It's the only thing that
is not deterministic.
So, what will you do to have like a
deterministic output?
We'll have T equal to zero.
T equal to zero, you know for sure
that your output will be just one thing
and nothing else.
Well,
that's what is kind of
the theoretical
property, but
in practice,
you have some stuff that is happening in
the computation
that introduces some
non-deterministic
operations. So, it's very much more
advanced than the scope of this class.
Much more advanced of the scope of this
class. I just want to call out that in
practice, T equal to zero may lead to
different results because of this
kind of practical piece.
So, what I recommend, so there's a
suggested reading, just you're
completely optional.
So, there is a very recent article
around defeating non-determinism in LM
inference.
So, I recommend that you read it in case
you're interested. So, the high-level
idea is
our GPUs are hardware,
when they reduce
some of these operations,
sometimes they are reducing numbers that
are on really different scales.
So, the order at which these operations
are happening is actually quite
important.
So, the idea is if these operations they
happen in different order,
it's may lead to different results.
Even if in theory it should be exactly
the same, in practice it may not be the
same.
And this article actually does a great
job at just explaining the intuition.
So, yeah, just if you're interested,
completely optional.
Cool. I know I'm kind of late, so I
guess
last thing that I want to say is
let's suppose what you want to do is to
generate an output in a very specific
format, let's suppose a JSON, JSON
format.
So, I guess a very naive approach would
be to tell your LLM, well, uh please
generate this in let's say JSON.
And then it produces something, and then
you kind of
uh try to see if it's a valid JSON. If
it's not, you repeat, you just tell it
to generate again
until it uh does something well. So,
that's the first naive approach.
Well, there is a second approach
that is called guided decoding.
And what that does is during the
generation process
it filters out
what it calls invalid next tokens.
So, here uh let's suppose I want to
generate this JSON.
I know for sure that my first token must
be uh something that opens the, you
know, the
I forgot what the English word was for
this, but, you know, it's just opens the
the brackets, yeah.
Open the brackets. So, you can only have
this.
And then you can only have the property
name, it's and so on and so forth.
And sometimes you can have more than one
permitted next token, in which case you
would go back
to our, you know, next token strategy.
Yeah.
So, the question is how do you restrict
uh the the other tokens? So, there's a
bunch of papers that go into that. We
will not cover this, but I can give you
some pointers. Uh just type finite state
machine FSM,
uh context grammar. So, there's a bunch
of papers that do that. We will not
cover that here.
Cool. And I think with that we will uh
go to the second part
uh with Sherwin.
>> Great.
Thank you, Aashish.
So, uh now together we're going to look
at different prompting strategies. So,
now that we know how responses are
generated, we're going to see how to get
responses and how to get great
responses.
So, let's go back to our favorite
example about our cute teddy bear.
So, just I want to introduce one piece
of vocabulary. So, when you have some
kind of input,
you have the length of your input
measured in number of tokens.
And you will see in the literature that
it can have different names. So, you can
see it called context length,
context size, window size. And I think
the latest tools, like if you code on,
you know, cursor or any other code
assistant tool, I think they call it
more context length. But like all these
terms are
equivalent.
And they know the same thing.
Okay.
So,
now I want to take some time to discuss
like what can be some orders of
magnitude here. So,
like modern day LLMs, they tend to be in
the order of magnitude of tens of
thousands, hundreds of thousands, or
millions of input tokens as inputs. So,
this is the kind of input it can take.
So, sometimes you hear some new LLM
boost some number. And then that number
of context length is exactly that. So,
it's like how much tokens can it
accommodate in a single pass?
Okay, great. And then yeah, the models,
so you have seen like maybe some like
advertisement of these models. So, I
think like Gemini and others, they're in
the million territory.
Um
and you know, does that mean it's all
nice and pretty? You know, do we if we
have like more context length, is it
going to solve everything?
Actually not.
There is a phenomenon that was recently
dubbed as context rots in a paper from
earlier this summer
where basically the authors
are experimenting the capacity of the
model to retrieve some piece of
information uh in a test called needle
in a haystack. So, basically they ask
some question
and in larger and larger pieces of text,
they bury the answer.
And they they try to look at the
capacity of the model to surface that
answer.
And then you can see that with respect
to an increasing context length, that
ability to ground the information with
the answer that is in the context
decreases.
And uh yeah, the paper I think is a very
interesting one. It uh like controls
with respect to what else is in the
context. Like there is a term of like
distractors where they like put some
noise and then they see distractors
basically contributes
in uh decreasing the retrieval
capability. So, you know, also what is
in your context matters.
Um so, this is why in general when you
have a retrieval problem where you want
to use your LLM to solve it,
you have some good incentive to try to
target as much as possible the right
piece of context for your LLM to see and
predict on.
Okay, great.
And yep.
>> Yes. So, the con-
Yes, so the question is uh is the
context length exactly what is shown
during self-attention? Uh yes.
Yeah.
So, and then we're going to see So, I
think we saw last time
that uh sometimes there are like some uh
tricks that are used for the like
complexity of the self-attention
mechanism not to be n squared. So, this
is what is being used to uh like manage
basically the complexity of the
computations as the context length
grows. Yeah, but it was a great callout
that that's exactly uh what it is about.
Okay, great. Any questions? Any other
questions?
Okay, great.
Um so, now let's define
what do uh prompts usually look like.
So, there is no formal theory on how to
structure a given prompt, but this is
these are the main lines that are
usually found in uh the prompts
presented to models. So, you can
distinguish a part that is uh like
setting up the context where you like
just put the setting, you know, you you
make it clear to the model what's, you
know, kind of
query you want to to issue. Then, uh
let's say if you have some task that you
want the model to perform, have
instructions.
And then these instructions are like
some sort of function that take as input
something. So, you add some inputs.
And uh in order to get what you want out
of the model's response, you may want to
add some constraints
uh out of it. So, here we we took our
favorite example with a teddy bear. Uh
the context is, you know,
like what is the teddy bear
basically like what is the mood of the
teddy bear? What do we want
uh you know, to do in order to um like
make our teddy bear happy, and then uh
we we give some inputs regarding where
the story that we want to generate is,
and then uh we give some constraints.
If you want some other example uh in the
LLMs that you query every day
So, the context could be um you know
some sentence that says, "You are
ChatGPT. It is uh you know, we are
October 10th.
Uh it is uh 4:44 p.m."
So, you set the setup.
The instructions can be uh basically
what the user queries alongside the
inputs.
And then constraints might be things
that you don't see as a user, but that
might be um you know, present in the
prompts given to the LLM such as safety
instructions. For example, do not
generate any contents that might lead to
harm or things like this.
So, you know, every time you see an
input being fed to an LLM uh I think
these projection into four these four
dimensions can be a good mental model of
seeing, you know, which pieces
correspond to what goal um in in that
structure.
Does that make sense?
Okay, great. So, now that we know uh
like what kind of mindsets we might have
for inputs to an LLM, let's see how we
can get an LLM to do what we want.
And let's see how we can get an LLM to
do what we want without tuning any
weights.
And we can do so with a concept called
in-context learning where the learning
is a bit
of a term that is overloaded because you
don't actually learn anything with
respect to the weights of the LLM.
But you can
uh like distill some knowledge
inside of it um you know, as part of the
context
in order to do what you want.
So, you distinguish two main categories
of in-context learning.
So, there is one category that is very
simple, you know, in mindset, it's
called zero-shot. It's basically you
don't give
anything other than your inputs, um,
your input query, you know, you you just
ask the LLM to do what what you want to
do.
And then there is another, uh, school of
thought called a few-shot learning where
you give examples of inputs and outputs
to the LLM before asking the input that
you're interested in.
So, in the case of a teddy bears and a
bedtime stories, so you might, you know,
name your teddy bear. So, maybe you have
a teddy teddy bear that's called teddy
and you generated a story. So, you put
your query, you put the story that you
want to generate
and you give multiple such examples.
And let's say you have another teddy
bear that's called,
you know, Bob, you know, and then you
want to generate a story for Bob. So,
you put all of these examples and you
ask the LLM to generate,
uh, the story that you're interested in
and then this is basically what we call
the few-shots
setting.
Okay, great. So, now,
um, generally, when you look at the
performance of the of the given, um,
like of the resulting task,
giving examples tends to steer the LLM
nicely into the task that you're
interested in just because
you have like given an idea to the model
of what you are looking for. And then it
can use what it has learned during its
training process to connect the dots
and,
uh, basically replicates,
um, and then,
uh, Uh, but of course you need to gather
such examples, so this is costly. Uh,
this will put some more, uh, tokens in
the context window, so you will need to
like more computes.
Uh, but
uh, there is an interesting trade-off
here that we see in recent models. So,
they're gaining more and more reasoning
capabilities,
which is why I put the generally, um,
nuance in italic here. So, they're
generally better few-shots, but not
always.
Because these days, uh, with these like
better models,
people have seen that with, uh, like
basically making the instruction better,
you could make the performance of
in-context learning on par or even
better than if you provide examples.
Cuz basically, when you think of it,
when you provide examples, you constrain
your model into given sets of examples
that are finite. So, when you are at
inference time, let's say you want to
perform a task on a distribution of data
that has not been seen, it is harder for
the model to generalize because it will
try
to align on what it has seen in the
context, whereas if you turn your
instructions into something that is more
reasoning-based, you explain how to do
the task with natural language, it can
use its reasoning abilities to actually
do it. And then, this is something that
you see more and more these days.
So, the literature on this, I think, is
still in in progress, but you have some
papers like your plan and solve,
uh, that's, I think, came out recently
and that showed, you know, if you ask
the LLM to plan itself and then solve
something, uh, it can have very good
performance.
So, yeah, this is an interesting
um, this is an interesting fact.
Okay, great.
So now that we have seen
uh basically the kinds of learning that
we have, now we're going to see what we
can do to improve the quality of the
response.
So there is this concept called chain of
thoughts
where uh researchers have seen
that if you force the model to come up
with some rational
to some answer before actually giving it
it would give higher performance.
So this is what you what people call as
chain of thought. It's basically what
has led you to the answer.
So here for example if you uh you know,
ask yourself, you know, how old is this
teddy bear?
And if you force the model to respond
directly with a number
it might not be able to do the
connection as to exactly why the teddy
bear is a given age.
Whereas when you give the kind of full
chain of reasoning, then it becomes
clearer as to, you know, what led to
that response. So I think this is the
main mindset behind this technique.
And uh basically this is something that
is that can be used in in-context
learning. So if you give uh like
few-shot examples, you know how old was
the was this teddy bear? You give some
number and then you slightly change the
query and then based on the reasoning
formatting and then the response, the
LLM can adjust the reasoning and the
response accordingly. And it will force
the model to output some reasoning
alongside the response, which shows
an improvement in um in basically uh
metrics.
Okay, great. And then yeah, something
else that I want to say you know, let's
say you are uh you want to do a task and
you want to do it well. You know,
oftentimes you will always have some
samples that do not work.
And then for them you want to have
debugging ability, right?
And uh usually when you debug with LLMs,
you don't debug like the old days. You
don't look at weights at at the
intrinsics of the LLM.
What you want is something
more interpretable that comes out of it
in terms of tokens.
And usually uh you know, with these
techniques, you can see the reasoning
that the model had before outputting a
given response. And you can debug
basically what went wrong.
So, if you ask
"How old will will the bear be next
year?" and if in the chain of thoughts
it says uh "Hey, we're in 2019."
You know that somehow in your context,
you know, oh, maybe I put the wrong
dates, you know, in there. So, you can
like trace back to You can do some root
causing
very easily.
So, it's also used for that. And
uh you know, exactly
in the same way as other techniques that
increase the number of tokens, this is a
trade-off that you have to manage that
it will of course take more time
uh you know, to infer because you need
to to generate more tokens.
But typically we're fine with it.
Any questions on COT?
Okay, great. So, now let's take it one
step further.
Um
so, I want to introduce, you know, even
to make COT
even stronger, you can sample your model
several times,
look at the answers it generates,
and then do some majority voting
to select the answer that was predicted
most of the times by a given LLM, and
this is what we call self-consistency,
where basically you sample responses
multiple times, and then parse
the actual answer. So, basically you
kind of factor out the whole reasoning
and then try to target the answer and
then by majority voting you can come up
to an answer in a more um
robust way.
Yep.
Yep. So, the question is do you need to
have some benchmarks to know if it's
better? And yes, absolutely. I think the
paper operates on top of all the
arithmetic and then mathematical based
ones. And then I think one tangential
question to yours is how can you locate
the answer and then do major majority
voting on it? So, typically you can put
into the context some instruction that
says put the actual answer last.
So, you can just like extract the last.
People I think uh use regex based
techniques otherwise to extract the
answer or you could even think of using
some other LLM to extract the answer.
So, there is always a way to kind of do
it. Uh but uh yeah, to your point, yes,
we need uh some benchmark and then
ground truth labels to assert that this
is indeed better.
Yep. So, the request here So, the
question is uh is it going to be sent to
the same request as example? So,
typically you sample it in parallel. So,
basically you ask your model exactly
what I've seen just mentioned. You
sample from the probability distribution
of BOS and whatever tokens you had the
next token and you do that in a several
other uh kind of branches.
And you do that all of that in parallel.
And then you kind of parse the answer at
the end of it.
So basically the latency of this process
is equal roughly to the maximum latency
of either parallel generation because
you can do all of this in parallel.
Yeah. So no So none of these go into the
context of each other. They're all done
in parallel and then you get final
answer.
Great.
All good?
Okay, great. So now that we have seen a
few prompting techniques,
I want to cover together
tricks that people have come up with at
inference time to make the generation as
efficient as possible. So
Um and basically yeah, so in modern-day
models you have a lot of parameters. You
want to generate a lot of tokens. How do
you do it the most efficient efficiently
possible? So I want to ask
to divide this thought process into two
parts. So we're going to see, you know,
what methods we can come up with that
give up that give us increased
efficiency on an exact level. So you
exactly do the same computations as you
were supposed to do, but you know, in a
more efficient way and I put some
um you know, hints as to what kind of
techniques we're going to explore. So
you know, let's stay Let's try to look
for techniques that avoid redundancies.
Let's try to see what we could do to
manage the memory in the best way.
Uh reformulate
the equations inside the LLM in a way
that could simplify the the generation
in practice.
Then there is a second category that
we're going to explore as well
that is going to focus on what kind of
approximations it might be fine to do
and get a high quality answer
at a
at at a lesser cost.
But, you know, it will be approximate.
So, we have, you know, what kind of um
variations we could do on the
architecture? Is there something we
could do on the embeddings um to make
them more efficient? And then maybe on
the token prediction side, is there
something we could uh do to make it you
know
faster?
Does that sound good?
So, we have approximately 22 minutes.
We're going to try to go through all of
them
um here.
Okay, so
I grouped the categories of techniques
into exact and approximate techniques.
Uh but actually, we're going to look at
them in a grouped manner.
First looking at the attention layer,
uh seeing what kind of techniques we
could um have there. And then in the
second time in the second part,
we're going to look at the output layer
and then see, you know, what we can do
at the level of token generation to make
things uh you know, as as good as
possible.
Okay, so let's start at the attention
level.
So,
we have seen
that uh you know, for every token,
you need the current token to attend to
the previous ones, right?
In this masked self-attention.
So, let's say you generate your
sequence. You are at given token, so
let's say, you know, you have generated
a cute teddy bear and then now you are
at is.
Now you have the query is.
You will
compute the key representation and the
and the value representation of is
because, of course, you have to do it.
It's your current token.
But we want
to have a way to reuse the past
computations we had done to compute the
key representation of the previous
tokens and the value representation of
the previous tokens.
Does that make sense as a goal?
Does everyone agree?
Okay.
And more precisely, basically we want to
find a way for the key and value
matrices
to be saved. And you know, I'm not
underlining the the Q parts here because
of course the query corresponding to the
previous tokens
are not going to be of interest for the
the present token.
So it's like the key and value part.
Okay.
So there is
like this concept of KV cache where the
goal is to store this key and value
matrices somewhere.
Um
and reuse them directly from the cache.
So like what I just mentioned here, you
know, when you want to compute a given
token, you would reuse the key and the
value directly from the cache instead of
computing it again.
So yeah, so
Um yeah, so this is basically
you know, representation of what we just
mentioned here.
Um yeah, does that make sense?
Okay, awesome.
So what else we could could we do? Oh
yeah.
Yeah, great question. So during
training, do we do KV caching? I would
say during training, you have this
concept of teacher forcing where you put
all your inputs and pass it all together
at once. So, this concept of key
vacation caching doesn't even come up.
Uh yeah.
Yeah, but great one. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah. So, the question was you know,
what is the point of all this? We want
to just reuse like the
computations that were already done and
then your answer is yes, spot on.
Any other questions?
Okay, great. So, now that we have seen
you know, that we could cache these
quantities. So, what else could we do?
So, is there something from last week's
lecture
that we could reuse? You know, maybe
something that reduces the amount of
cache
you know, the key and value.
Do we have some techniques?
Sparse attention.
Um
Yeah, that could be. That could be. But
not here. Like let's say you are not you
are tending to everyone
and you focus on the number of keys and
values. Is there a way to reduce this
number? So, just to recap, we have
here I'm operating in the context of
multi-headed attention, which is you
have your H heads.
So, you have H
number of query projections, H key
projections, H value projections. Is
there Is there any technique
from last week that we could reuse that
could reduce this number?
Yeah, I heard it. Yeah, group query
attention, yeah, exactly.
So, we had this,
um,
you know, concept of grouping
keys and values together,
uh, where basically the general
formulation is called group query
attention, where you group these, and
then the external values
H and 1 denote respectively the full
multi-headed attention, and then
multi-query attention.
And then in, uh, modern-day LLMs, uh,
like a lot of papers they use
uh, GQA,
uh, with with some, uh, group that is,
uh, sensible value. Yeah.
So, this is also something we can do.
Okay, great.
And now I'm going to go a little bit
into the hardware side of things.
So, if we were to store the cache for
all these values in a naive way, you
know, at inference time, so let's say
you receive So, let's say I'm an
inference
server, I receive queries from multiple
users,
and let's say I receive a query one, and
I receive a query two,
um, you know, a naive way of storing the
key and and value, um,
you know, matrices would be in reserving
a pro- a portion of the memory
at the beginning that correspond to the
entire context length,
because you don't know, you know, where
you're going to stop, right? You're
decoding, because you stop your decoding
when you hit the EOS token.
So, you would have like this whole block
of size, uh, you know, context length,
like maximum context length, that could
be reserved.
So, one observation is that it leads to
a lot of waste.
So, let's say if your context length is
of size like 2K, you have, uh, 2K
reserved for a given, uh, you know,
request, 2K there. So, at any given
time, like let's say you want to get
more requests, you want to serve more
requests, your memory will very quickly
not have enough space to uh accommodate
uh them.
Does this constraints or does this
challenge make sense?
Yeah.
Okay, and then there is this paper
that's that is called page detention and
it defines several
like
quantities. So, there is this like
reserved quantity, internal
fragmentation, and external
fragmentation. Internal fragmentation is
basically the space that is being
reserved by the model to complete the
request.
And the reserved spot is the subset of
it
that corresponds to tokens that were
actually being used. So, it's the kind
of space that's actually used in the
internal fragmentation. There is nothing
in there, but this was reserved.
And external fragmentation, it's the
memory management system that doesn't
necessarily put one you know, block one
after another, but has its own way of
allocating
memory blocks. So, it might leave some
other gaps.
And they came up with a system that is
called a page detention that is you
know, powering one inference
package called the vllm
that
solves this issue by mapping
like the generation process by blocks of
fixed size. So, instead of uh
allocating a whole portion of the memory
to answer a given request, it breaks it
down by smaller chunks.
So, I think the paper takes like a value
of 16 for blocks. So, as you can see,
let's say you are in your generation
process and you have used a given row,
you just start using another row without
um you know, wasting more space than
that.
And then you have some dictionary that
maps
token position indices to uh to
basically their their cash values. So,
there is like a smart way of managing
it.
And they show that it reduces
fragmentation by quite a lot.
Yeah.
Okay, great.
Now, let's do something else with this
KV cache.
So, uh we just saw that, you know,
you have your internal representation of
your token and you project it into
query, key, and value.
And then key and value
is actually something that is of a
dimension that is like non-negligible
and you need to store uh eight copies of
it in each transformer block.
So, you have many of these uh vectors
that you need to keep track of.
And is there a way to make that
representation somehow more compact?
And this is a topic that
uh DeepSeek has um you know, tried to
tackle in a concept called
um I think it was called
multi-latent
attention.
We're going to see
uh so, you know, let's look at the
vanilla case. You know, if you are in
multi-headed attention,
then for a given representation of a
token, you have
eight projection matrices that turn it
into a key.
Does everyone agree with that?
So, it's the kind of
uh self-attention formula, you know, you
have a projection matrix W K for keys
that will project the token
representation into some key, and you
have H heads.
You have
H such projections, and you have H such
resulting embeddings that you need to
store in your cache.
Cuz you have that for keys, you have
that so for values.
That's a lot of,
um,
vectors to store. And these keys and
values, they are, uh, you know,
quite long as well. Uh, so let's see if
we can like, um,
make it smaller.
What it's multi-latent attention
does is that it factorizes these,
um, you know, projection matrix
into an intermediary space that is of
lower dimension than the space of keys.
You have a first transformation that
reduces the dimension, and then another
one that decompresses it.
So this is the first,
uh,
operation kind of that they did in order
to make the representation
more compact.
But they did something else that is very
smart.
They said
that the compression matrix
could be shared
across keys and values.
Which says
for a given token representation,
the cache that you need to store for
keys and for values is the same.
And then you would have, um, you know,
still different matrices here for the
decompression part to like actually
learn different representations
for a key and value,
but you know, one
um, simplification here has to like
share it for like across keys and
values.
And even better, share it across the H
heads.
So, instead of having H search
embeddings, you have just one.
Uh, and then you do that, you know, for
key, you do that for value. So, at the
end of it, for every Transformer block,
you have a single representation per
token.
Does that make sense?
So, not only
you have, like, you know, less things to
store, the Deep Seek V2 paper also
showed a performance improvement that
it's
uh, kind of
credited like some regularization um,
consequence of doing so. So, it it
learns representations that are maybe
more useful and shared across keys and
values. So, you know, apparently there
is also um,
performance benefits to it that is not
just
hardware-based.
Okay, great. So, now we have seen some
trick Oh, yeah.
Yeah, so the question is, do you tune
the low-rank dimension? So, the
dimension itself is a design choice.
It's fixed.
So, the question is, is it the same uh,
like, lower dimension for everyone? So,
the dimension size is fixed and is the
same for everyone, I think. So, but it's
a design choice. Yeah, you you could
have different ones.
But, I think in practice it's it might
be the same one.
Yep.
Any other questions?
Okay, great. So, now we have less than
10 minutes. We are going to cover
techniques that operate at the output
token level.
Um, and then start with a concept called
speculative decoding that is
kind of a very interesting method
that uses some smaller model
to help the generation of a bigger model
and then uses some scheme
that makes the distribution outputs
match the one of the target one.
So it uses a combination of tricks of
using like a smaller model to generate
things and then gates it with some
mathematical based properties
to ensure we get a distribution that
looks like the one of the big model.
So
here's what is the mind like here's the
mindset of it.
So let's just come back to our favorite
example about teddy bears.
So what you do
is that you ask a a smaller model
uh that we that the paper calls draft
to generate next words. So you have like
my teddy bear, you know, what could be
next words? So you have one pass, you
know, you find token is, you feed token
is here again, you find cute and smart.
Since the LLM is small, this is
typically done faster than with the big
LLM.
And then once you have all of these, you
put the tokens that are predicted by the
smaller LLM
all as inputs
to the target
uh LLM that is like the bigger model,
like the one that you use
to generate probability distributions
for each of them.
And then we're going to see
that by having some rule
on the output distribution of each of
these tokens
you can simulate
uh distribution a probability
distribution of each token of each next
token
that's um kind of looks like the one of
the target models.
So here's
basically how it goes.
So it looks at the probability of the
the token that the draft model has
predicted. So if the probability of the
draft model is bigger than the one of
the draft model in the draft models
output distribution, then you just
accept the token.
Otherwise, you have some acceptance
rejection mechanism that either accepts
the token or rejects it.
And
you know, let's say everything is
accepted. Then in a single pass, you
were able to advance, you know, by way
more tokens.
And then if it fails, then basically you
resume the process of generation from
that token onwards with some adjustments
on the distribution.
So
one question that you might ask from all
of this, you know,
this looks like a recipe. Why is that
matching the target distribution?
So if you start from the law of total
probability and write each term
with these quantities,
then you will find the target
distribution at the end. So it's an
exercise that I encourage you to do. And
the
paper that is attached to the slide here
demonstrates it in like a just a few
lines. So it's a very simple proof.
And I think it's a very very interesting
one.
Does that Does that make sense? Yep.
Yep. So I think it's a yep. The question
is is that rejection something? Yep.
So some of you might be familiar with
it's already.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, and then one thing that I didn't
say
is that why did we even put the last
token here? You know, we put all the
draft tokens but also the last one that
was predicted because by doing a single
forward pass with all these draft
tokens, you get for free the probability
distribution of the token that comes
after that that you can then just sample
from
Q K + 1.
So, like just to give some summary of
the rational
um
doing a single pass
is like as expensive as doing one pass
at a time because at inference time you
are memory bound. Like in other words,
uh computations are not the limiting
factor. It's basically the memory that
will bottleneck your computation. So,
you want to do it on a smaller model and
then on the big models, you want to
compute all of these probability
distributions at once.
Does that make sense?
Okay, great.
And then I want to talk about one last
technique that is called multi-token
prediction.
It's the same uh though so by the way,
this previous technique was called
speculative decoding.
And then this one
is basically doing the same
but so it's doing exactly a different
thing but the draft model is embedded in
the same model, which is a very
powerful. So, basically it's a model
that
uh
attaches multiple heads on top of the
representation of the last decoder.
And the process here is that at training
time it doesn't do next word prediction.
It does multi word prediction.
And at test time the draft model is all
your heads
and your main model is just the first
head. So, you have like all your drafts
tokens that you then feeds back to the
first head and then do accept acceptance
and rejection. So, the paper does it in
a greedy way. So, it doesn't do it with
this like formula because since the
architecture and then the objective
function has changed, you don't have
this like nice property of finding again
the like next token predictions
distribution.
But, you have like a slight variation of
it.
And yeah, so like the interesting notes
out of the multi token prediction is the
change in objective function and then
seconds the
the fact that the draft model and the
target model are basically embedded in
the same one.
So, don't have to like separate the two.
And
yeah, so you do remember the slides. We
have explored techniques that can remedy
each of these aspects. So, yeah, I
highly recommend, you know, taking a
look at the associated papers as well.
And with that,
thank you very much.